We're all moving so fast.
What if, just for a moment, we stopped.
There are problems with everything and nothing's yet perfect,...
...but that shouldn't be cause to bemoan.
That should be cause to achieve.
We're living at an all-time high for health and wellness,...
...and literacy has been sharply on the rise for decades.
More people are living longer.
And during childbirth, both infant and maternal mortality rates...
...have plummeted in the last century, saving the lives of millions.
We live the way we do because people chose to tackle their problems head-on.
When thinking if you're going to be optimistic this year, remember:...
...nobody changes the world on their own.
It all starts with a resolution.
What's yours?